le sport l'une des résolutions phare des
français pour 2017 selon un sondage
réalisé par ipsos l'activité sportive
représentent 30% des bonnes résolutions
de cette année et peut-être que ça sera
le début de l'année ya beaucoup de gens
qui me donne de bonnes résolutions il ya
beaucoup iront dans sa voix ses bonnes
résolutions à prendre ça fait du bien et
que même ça change je me suis inscrit la
ja il ya un mois à la salle donc c'est
tout nouveau et donc voilà c'est parti
bah oui pourquoi pas enfin là et décide
un petit peu avant et du coup la chimie
mais pour cette année me motive tapis de
course biking ou fitness les débutants
peuvent évoluer sur des machines simples
d'utilisation pour se remettre en jambes
en douceur et le mieux après les fêtes
c'est le cardio et la musculation en
général qui revient souvent c'est les
personnes qui veulent perdre de la masse
grasse ça est plutôt orienté cardio avec
toute une partie renforcement musculaire
derrière et après c'est les personnes en
général c'est de la prise de masse prise
de volume
donc après c'est vraiment accès plus tôt
sur la musculation que sur la partie
cardio c'est d'être régulier ça je pense
que c'est l'importance que beaucoup de
personnes qui vont sûrement s'inscrit en
janvier on va les voir pendant un mois
et puis un mois
puis en l'air vers un mois de juin quoi
on se préparait pour la plage ouverte
depuis décembre cette nouvelle enseigne
de montigny le bretonneux a déjà boosté
ses abonnements elle espère entre 200 à
700 nouveaux adhérents pour le mois de
janvier et reste à tenir ses bonnes
résolutions au moins jusqu'à l'an
prochain